-My first guest is
a 16-time WWE champion,
a best-selling author,
and a talented actor,
who stars in "F9,"
which is in theaters
this Friday.
Please welcome John Cena!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's my man!
That's what I'm talking about.
-Thank you very much.
-That's how you do it.
That's what I'm talking about.
-No, no.
-Yes.
-I should do it --
Man, I wish I was there.
I really --
Seeing all the people
and seeing you in front of an
audience makes me feel great.
I want to say hi to everybody.
I'm sorry I'm not there.
I can't wait to be there
next time.
-You will. Oh, please.
You're the greatest.
Come on.
I love that you dressed up, too.
That is very cool. Thanks.
-No, no, this is
what I slept in.
-Oh, alright.
Sorry I thought -- Yeah.
I apologize.
Hey, I want to congratulate
you on the air.
Congratulations.
You got married, buddy.
That's awesome.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm so happy for you.
-Jimmy, you've met my wife
multiple times,
and I consider you
a true friend.
You're the only one I'll say --
I'll accept a
congratulations from.
-Yeah.
We were just
talking about wedding fails.
We just did a hashtag.
Have you ever experienced
a wedding fail?
-Yeah, I think that's something,
kind of, we all have.
Mine was my brother
Matt's wedding.
I thought it would be a nice
gesture to open the bar.
Drinks are on me.
That's my gift to
the bride and groom,
that nobody would have to
pay for anything.
So, I found out it was a mistake
when my brother Dan and I
got into a fistfight in
the middle of the dance floor
and closed the wedding down.
-Oh, my God.
-Yeah.
And you could tell
right then and there
who were guests and who were
a member of the Cena family,
because the guests were like,
"Stop it!"
And the Cena family's like, "No,
no, let them figure it out."
-Yeah, let them do that. Yeah.
-Let them do it.
-Yeah, I want to
ask you about this,
'cause, you know, I follow you
on all the socials.
And you're a great follow.
And I follow you on Instagram.
There's rumors.
There's rumors that
you're returning to the ring.
-Those rumors are true.
I'll be -- I'll definitely be
back to the WWE.
I just -- I don't know when.
-Okay. But, so, this got fans
freaking out, okay?
-Yeah, so, I posted that
back in May.
I was feeling rather
nostalgic about the WWE
and I just wanted to
post the logo.
And some people took it as
I was returning immediately,
which that's not the case.
But I haven't had my last match
and I can't wait to have
my next one.
-Well, you have
giant movies coming out.
Like, giant, giant, giant films.
-Well, I mean,
I'm very fortunate.
You know, "F9" is this week.
I'm very excited they let people
back in theaters to see that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-"Suicide Squad."
Currently filming "Peacemaker."
A comedy named
"Vacation Friends"
is coming out.
-"Vacation Friends"
looks awesome, by the way.
-All these opportunities
have led to more opportunities.
So, I've said before, once you
do one of these things,
the insurance doesn't let you go
wrestle on the weekends.
So we'll see what happens.
-"F9," like we said,
hits theaters Friday,
and people are going to come out
and go see movies again,
if it's safe, which is great.
I think this is
the perfect movie for that.
You play Vin Diesel's brother.
I saw on Vin's Instagram
when he kind of announced
that you were going to be --
How did it work?
Because Vin is very --
Like, he's very, kind of --
There's a lot of
mystique around him.
I'll say, "How are you doing?"
He's like,
"Isn't today beautiful?"
Yeah.
-So, your facial expression
was kind of like mine.
I heard that Vin
wanted to talk to me.
I knew nothing, like,
about what.
So, here I am in L.A.
on business,
dressed like this, and I go just
talk to Vin Diesel.
And we hung out for
a couple of hours.
We talked about
a bunch of stuff.
And I thought it was
just really cool.
And at the end,
he takes out his phone
and films a social video.
And if you go check this video
out, you can see me at the end.
-Yeah.
-And I'm like...
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.
Yeah, that's --
-And I don't even know
what's going on.
He didn't even let me
know afterwards, and I left.
I'm like, "Man, I just
hung out with Vin Diesel,"
and I thought that was
the end of it.
And then they called me later
and said they wanted me
to be in the "F9."
And then he called me
later on and said,
actually what I was doing,
which is, you know,
being the brother of
Dom Toretto.
That's -- If you're a fan
of the universe,
that's like your first match
being in the main event
at WrestleMania.
So I was really, really
excited about that,
and the gravity of that
is certainly not lost on me.
-And did you guys --
Did you guys bond?
-We did.
He's a wonderful human being.
And, man, like, his decision
has changed my life.
And not only that,
the camaraderie and the family
on the "Fast" set is real.
Like, everybody spends time
with everybody.
You got to remember,
these people have been
doing business together
for 20 years.
This is --
"Fast" just celebrated
its 20th anniversary yesterday.
-That's right.
-So it's only fitting that,
you know,
we release "F9" this Friday
and get everybody
going to the theaters.
But they've become
like a family,
and it was so
welcoming and awesome.
And, yeah, there was
some good, quality bonding.
-You guys got some
good, scrappy fights in there.
-Yeah. So, you know, I think
I'm a good reference plate
that the more you
beat the tar out of a guy,
the more, you know,
you tend to bond with him.
In WWE,
that's kind of what we do.
But, no, he --
-Do you think he could
hold his own in the WWE?
-He already has a name
and his name describes
his fighting style -- Diesel.
-Diesel.
-He is a bull in a china shop.
I tell it like,
he is the most --
Like you said, he's like --
He's got his own mystique
and he's very loving
and warm and kind,
but with the action stuff,
you can kind of see him
get in that zone.
And I'm like,
"Yeah, this is...
Okay."
-Then you get scared.
You go, "Oh, he's in character.
Alright, here we go."
-Yeah, and then just it's really
energetic and it's --
He would be a --
You know, if the movie
biz doesn't work out for him,
he would be
a WWE champion for sure.
-Yeah. I think he's doing okay.
Yeah.
Should we set up the film
at all for anyone
who doesn't know
the plot of "F9"?
-Yeah, I mean, here's the setup.
Hey, guys, there's a
huge blockbuster, "F9,"
released on Friday, and
we've been without theaters
and cinematic experiences for...
way too long!
Go to the movie theater
and see this movie,
'cause it's wonderful!
Pay for the whole seat
and use only the edge!
-That's what I'm talking --
Oh! That's what I'm talking...
Is he a pro or what?
"Use only the edge."
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's John Cena
and Vin Diesel in "F9."
Take a look at this.
-That's what I'm talking about!
John Cena, everybody!
-We actually re-created my
brother Matt's wedding for that.